so i've been noticing over the past few
years that the
the mainstream sports media not only are
they left-wing but they've decided that
they're just going to cover for any
left-wing athlete they can find
if you're a right-wing athlete or even a
moderate athlete you will be
out on your ass so fast it'll make you
swim and if your myers leonard
and you say the k word on a twitch
stream you will be thrown out to the
nether regions if you are lebron james
and you are popular and left to circles
for knowing nothing and being kind of a
bad person
when it comes to your politics if you
are that lebron james
you can literally just tweet out
anti-jewish slurs and nothing will
happen to you
like nothing okay that is the way the
media won't even take notice of this
they won't care
and myers leonard will be worth a
thousand barrels of spilled ink lebron
james doing bad things that's not worth
anything
nothing okay and this holds true for on
the court behavior as well
right so let's take lebron james over
the past couple of days so lebron
does not seem to be a very good teammate
okay let's just put it that way there
are a lot of people who have
been on lebron's team who don't seem
super happy about having been on the
bronze team he has this unfortunate
habit
of when his team loses blaming his
teammates and when his team wins
being king james that reared its ugly
head the other night
when the lakers were getting absolutely
blown out by the phoenix suns
so anthony davis who is who is the
second best player on the lakers lebron
being the best player on the lakers
he got hurt and uh and phoenix just blew
out
the lakers and the lakers had been up in
the series now they're down by one game
in the series
they're down 3-2 and frankly i think
america's now rooting pretty hard for
phoenix
and chris paul so there's like five and
a half minutes to go in this game
now one of the things that you don't
typically do is just abandon your
teammates on the sideline
right this is seen as a jerk thing to do
so here's lebron james making a jerk
move
what the phoenix is lebron walking off
the floor with 5
40 to go okay so 5-4 he just abandons
his teammates and walks in the locker
room which again
is a uh is a jerk move now the way
that this has been covered by the media
as well it's unfortunate that's kind of
unfortunate
and and it it's incredible that he's not
been
ripped up and down more than he has been
for this i mean i've been watching this
board and they've been doing this
they've been covering for lebron's
behavior like this for years this isn't
the first time lebron has walked off the
court
with time left on the clock last year he
walked off the court with time left
on the clock in the playoffs there's
still a few seconds left on the clock he
walked off the court
and he got the the sort of back massage
treatment from stephen a smith
and max kellerman mark jackson said
during the broadcast
it's a bad look for lebron do you agree
with him
yes i do but understand it's because
it's lebron
that i'm saying that it's not a big deal
in the grand scheme of things it wasn't
the end of the series or anything like
that there are other games to be played
it's just that lebron has created an
incredibly high standard for himself
i think in the media we can play it up
as a bigger deal because
this is really a testament to lebron's
greatness okay meanwhile frank vogel
his uh his coach said in terms of lebron
going in the back lebron
had to start his treatment it doesn't do
any good to sit over there without
getting worked on or beginning the
treatment as soon as possible
to help him get ready for game sex i'm
sure that that is um i'm sure that
that's what was going on
it wasn't that he was getting blown out
and was frustrated lebron after the game
by the way
he said yeah yeah we got our ass kicked
i don't know
man we got our ass kicked i mean it's
just that simple
um they did got to whatever they wanted
to get to in this game and uh
you know we got to be better obviously
if we want to force a game seven so
um obviously a lot to uh learn from in
this game a lot to cover
see uh you know what we got to do better
going to game six but uh
i mean they they pretty much just kick
their ass i mean there's nothing else
really to say okay so you know this
is kind of hell lebron acts fairly
regularly right again this is the second
time that he's done this in two years
and the media have treated him with kid
gloves over all of this and this is
because there is a broader move
that has been made in the sports media
to cover athletes on the basis
of their politics and to ignore
what would normally be seen as sort of
sports star responsibility
and the sports star responsibility now
attends to you need to wear a black
lives matter t-shirt
but you can be as much of a jerk as you
want to your teammates
that that seems to be the logic these
days and
it seems to never fail so long as the
media perceive you
as a victim of the white superstructure
you can do whatever you want
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video